هناك خطوه سابقه اقدم من الزيارتين
والمصافحه مهدت ارضيه الاصلاح والعوده او
عكست النوايا على الاقل في 2020 2021 عقد
البلدان السلسله جولات تشاوريه واستكشافيه
ضمت مسؤولين دبلوماسيين لم تسفر اي منها
عن تقدم يدرك الجانبان عمق الخلافات ولم
تاتي الخطوه نحو التطبيع الكامل الان الا
بعد تفاهمات مرضيه مشروطه لم تناقش علنا
لكن مصادر العربيه اكدت ان التفاهمات التي
تبدا من ليبيا تجاوبت معها انقره مصر
متمسكه بضروره توحيد المؤسسات الليبيه
ودعم اقامه الانتخابات في موعدها وضروره
تفكيك الميليشيات المسلحه وهي مطالب اكدت
بموجبها تركيا على اتخاذ الخطوات المناسبه
لتتماشى مع تطوير العلاقات مع مصر البلدين
المتشاركان لشرق البحر المتوسط المتنازع
على موارده من الطاقه والغاز الطبيعي
خصوصا طالبت مصر بضروره طلبه تركيا عفوا
بضروره وجود تفاهمات وتشاورات حول ملفات
ترسيم الحدود والغاز مجدده طلبها بالتواجد
في منتدى غازي شرق المتوسط وفي هذا الملف
عقد كثيره تحكمها اتفاقيه يعتبرها المجتمع
الدولي غير قانونيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]